now Brian green he's best known to the
public for popularizing string theory
and his earliest book the elegant
universe was a mega bestseller back in
1999 and it was followed up with a book
called the fabric of the cosmos space
time and the texture of reality now
that's that touches on so much and it it
enables him to think about so many
interesting branches of physics that
intrigue us and in 2003 there's a paper
published by a philosopher from the
University of Oxford on whether or not
the universe is a simulation and I had
to ask Brian Greene if he thought this
could actually be possible just to get
it get a professional opinion on this
let's find out if it's the case that one
day we can have computers that can
recreate a reality in bits and bytes
that has such verisimilitude that their
inhabitants of the simulations that feel
that it's real if that's possible I
think many of us agree that it might be
we're getting closer Eddie does let's
assume that's possible it's so much
easier to create a simulation than it is
to create a real universe I mean how you
going to create a real universe so if
you wait long enough they're going to be
many many more simulated universes and
there are real ones so any sentient
being if they're rational would think
that the odds are that they're in one of
those simulations because there's so
many more of those compared to real
statistically you're in the simulator
one not the real one yeah yeah exactly
so how do you know and it would be very
hard I mean some have suggested sort of
like in the matrix look for glitches
like real universes don't have glitches
but computers can have them but I said
that which is because uh presumably a
fallible entity programs that it could
be that it could be that it could also
be there's a electric current glitch
that happens in the real universe and
screws up what's happening inside the
computer but I don't buy that argument
because if it's a really good simulation
it should be able to rewind erase the
memory of a glitch fix it and then the
simulated beings have no memory of it
ever happening